>> Announcer: From the Library
of Congress in Washington D.C.
>> Laverne Page: Thank you
so much for coming today.
I would like to welcome you
to the Library of Congress,
to this concert, which I
expect to be wonderful.
I'm so pleased to see
you here and with us
to enjoy our visitors from Malawi.
My name is Laverne Page.
I'm in the African
section of the African
and Middle Eastern Division
here at the Library.
And my comments are short because
I want to have the time for you
to enjoy our visitors, our
performers from Malawi.
So, now I will introduce
the Chief of the African
and Middle Eastern Division,
Doctor Mary Jane Deeb.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Mary Jane Deeb: Thank you.
Thank you, Laverne
and your Excellency.
Ladies and Gentlemen,
good afternoon and welcome
to the Library of Congress.
I am Mary Jean Deeb, and I'm
delighted to see you all here
in the Whittall Pavilion
of the Library.
I'd like to thank Ambassador
Necton Mhura
for having made possible
this program.
He visited the Library
less than a month ago
and already we have a new project.
So, I mean, that's really wonderful.
This is a most appropriate location
to hold this very exciting cultural
and musical program from Malawi
with legendary performer
Giddes Chalamanda
and with I understand
Edgar and Davis
who are actually the
students of the Ambassador.
They are lawyers themselves.
The Whittall Pavilion is located
in the Thomas Jefferson building.
And this building was the
first separate Library
of Congress building,
which opened its doors
to the public on November 1st, 1897.
It represented an unparalleled
national achievement.
At that time, it had a 23-karat gold
plated dome capped with the largest
and costliest and safest dome.
And it had the Library
building, which was at that time,
the largest library
building in the world.
Its elaborately façade and
interior was designed by more
than 40 American painters
and sculptors
and surpassed any other
library building of its kind.
The Whittall Pavilion in which you
are now sitting was opened in 1939
and holds some of the
rarest musical instruments
in the world including
some Stradivarius violins,
which are there.
It has hosted numerous national and
international artists and musicians.
And so we are really happy
that we could host here
in this building Giddes
Chalamanda and his group.
As we mentioned, our
division, the African
and Middle East Division is
made up of three sections,
the African Section,
the Middle Eastern,
and the Hebraic section were
responsible for materials
from 78 different countries.
And we hold collections.
We do programs.
We do exhibits, and we
bring together our readers
and our visitors from all over
the world to hear and to enjoy
and to participate in the
culture programs that we hold.
And now do you want to start or do
you want to introduce or Ambassador,
would you like too say a
few words to our guests?
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Ambassador Necton Mhura:
Good afternoon everyone.
I also want to welcome
you to this performance
by the legendary Giddes Chalamanda.
He is 86 years old.
The story about Giddes
Chalamanda and Edgar
and Davis will be told
very briefly by Davis.
My job really is to introduce
something about Malawi.
Malawi is known as the
warm heart of Africa.
It's known as such
because it is friendly
and it is, it has smiling people.
You find people smiling
all over the country.
It is small as a country.
Land locked.
Bordered on the east and
southeast by Mozambique,
on the east by Zambia,
on the north by Tanzania.
Malawi is unique in sense
despite its relatively small size,
it has a number of tribes and clans
from the north to the south flanked
by a beautiful lake, which if I may
do a little tourism advert here,
I would advise everyone
and urge them to come
and visit the waters of Lake Malawi.
But most importantly, Malawi
is a very peaceful country.
Perhaps that's why
you hardly hear of it.
Dance and music are an
integral part of Malawian life.
Each of the tribes have their
strong cultures and beliefs
which give them their
own identities.
These cultures influence the
arts, particularly music.
Just to give a few examples
of Malawi and music.
There is vimbuza, which is
a traditional healing dance.
It is practiced in the
northern part of Malawi.
There is gule wamkulu, translated
literally, the big dance.
It is practiced in the
central region of Malawi.
Tchopa is a celebratory
and sacrificial dance.
It is important at this point to
mention that vimbuza, gule wamkulu,
and tchopa have been
recognized by UNESCO as part
of Malawi's intangible heritage.
Malawi and music largely mirrors
the diversity of Malawian culture
and is strongly influenced by
popular music sung by people
in the moonlight during
harvest times, weddings,
and such other locations
including funerals.
Modern day artists have used the
same traditional templates of music
to spread messages, social
developmental messages for instance
about HIV and AIDS, civic education
and such other developmental
matters.
To this end, therefore, one
would say that music is used
as a tool for social development.
Perhaps one would say a
tool of social engineering.
In my days as a law professor,
I used to say that law is a
tool for social engineering.
Now I am saying music is a
Giddes Chalamanda is a legend
in Malawian music and one
of the most recognizable
faces in Malawi.
He is 86 years old and has played
the guitar since he was a young boy.
He plays traditional music
and has composed many songs although
only a few have managed to make it
to the international stage
but he is still soldiering
on as perhaps you'll hear
from one of these songs called
"Buffalo Soldier,"
in which he talked
about his dreams to come to America.
Edgar and Davis are the
two young men that play
with him these days are
lawyers and part-time musicians
who have taken Giddes
Chalamanda as their protégé
for now close to 12 years.
Just as with Giddes Chalamanda, the
music duo of Edgar and Davis talk
of every day lives in their
music to ordinary Malawians.
Their songs are [inaudible]
fused with poetry, humor,
and a lot of double entendre.
They play folk music,
which is an adaptation
of traditional story telling
where African Children would sit
under a fire and listen
to stories told by elders,
which stories which will
be interspaced with music.
I said before, these stories
and songs make social
commentary are used
to educate people,
especially the youth.
Music like law, as I
saw, is therefore used
as a tool of social engineering.
And I would like to say by recording
Giddes Chalamanda at the Library
of Congress, we are making an
invitation to researchers to come
and study Malawian music.
One of the possible areas of study
that could be looked at is an impact
of music on societal
values and behavior.
Developmental practitioners
would therefore be interested
in that kind of research.
Edgar and Davis are in the U.S.
primarily to fulfill the dream
that Giddes Chalamanda
had as a young man to see
and taste the United
States of America.
Ladies and Gentlemen, I invite you
to enjoy this afternoon's
performance
by Giddes Chalamanda accompanied
by Edgar and Davis all the way
from Malawi, the warm art of Africa.
I will ask Davis to
say one or two things
about their collaboration
with Giddes.
And then we can get on to the
program, the musical program.
Thank you so much.
[ Applause ]
>> Davis Njobvu: Thank you
very much Ambassador Mhura.
I will just let my colleague Mr.
Edgar Kachere introduce the members
of the band.
>> Edgar Kachere: Thank
you very much.
Ambassador Mhura and everybody.
I am Edgar as already told.
And this is Davis.
We're accompanied by Uncle Lai.
Uncle Lai is a producer.
He has produced two
of our four albums.
So, he's a genius in his own right
and he's also a musician as well.
At the far end we have
Mr. Chimwemwe Maloya.
He does vocals for our band.
He's been with us for
more than ten years now.
So, he's part of the group.
And of course Mr. Giddes
Chalamanda himself.
So, I'll let Davis explain
a bit about our project.
>> Davis Njobvu: We
met, Edgar and myself,
we met in high school in Malawi.
I think that was in the early '90s.
We started playing in a school band.
Then we didn't really have much
in terms of technical knowledge,
but we did have a lot
of passion for music.
We had a school boy band.
And then later on, we met in college
where we were both doing law,
and we were being taught
by the Ambassador Mhura.
We still kept on playing music.
And this band, you know, started
as a duet between myself and Edgar.
We produced our first album I think
around 2000 after receiving a lot
of encouragement from students and
Malawians living around the college.
When I graduated, I was lucky
to meet Mr. Giddes Chalamanda.
And, you know, naturally
I introduced him to Edgar,
and we started playing together.
you know, because the
idea was to try and see
if we can give a platform
to Mr. Giddes Chalamanda
who has played music
for well over 40 years.
And he has, as the Ambassador said,
a very recognizable face in Malawi.
But we felt that he was not
maybe getting the recognition
that he should have been getting.
He was still carrying his guitar,
you know, every day walking
in town playing for less than,
I'm actually thinking it is
about a quarter of a dollar
for a song [multiple speakers].
We felt it wasn't right.
He should have maybe
had a bigger platform.
So, the whole idea was to
see if we can use the fact
that we are law students
and we're lawyers, you know,
maybe to fool some
people to inviting us.
And then we bring, we
thought the real deal.
You know, Giddes Chalamanda
comes now [inaudible] to perform.
So, we can see that
we're still managing
to fool some people [laughter]
because we are not the,
you know, it's not about us.
You know, the stage is
for Mr. Giddes Chalamanda.
And that is the idea of bringing
it to the United States of America.
You know, at the same time, as the
ambassador said, he sang a song.
This song has been
playing for 40 years.
He sang this song before
we were born.
You know, none of us were there.
He sang, "I would want
to go to America."
Today, he is in America.
I will not talk much.
I will just let him
say hello to you.
He does speak English, and he
understands everything I'm saying.
Mr. Giddes, could you greet the
people before we start playing
our songs.
>> Giddes Chalamanda:
Thank you very much.
Good morning all of you.
>> Audience: Good morning.
>> Giddes Chalamanda:
[inaudible] to me.
[inaudible] I don't
think that if I don't go
to [inaudible] America
very good country.
I see on the news [inaudible].
It was very good.
Now I am here to America to
see it's a very good country
and it's a very good city.
I am very [inaudible].
I am very happy we are here.
I can say anything.
Thanks very much.
>> Davis Njobvu: All right.
[ Applause ]
[ Music ]
So, I think that it will be perfect
if we can start with the song
that we say has been playing
for over 40 years where he sang
about wanting to come to America.
Enjoy the show.
OK.
[ Music ]
[ Applause ]
Thank you.
You see, one of the
things that amazes me
and I wish I had never found
out from Giddes Chalamanda is how
did he come to know about Indiana
and all those places, you know?
Because he was singing
this in the early '70s.
You know, that was
quite some way back.
But he had the knowledge.
You know, he knew where
he wanted to go.
And tomorrow he will be going to
Indiana to cross the boundaries
of Indiana and see America.
That's the song.
He has his own style of play.
You know, the style of singing as
you're going to see in this song.
He does something with his voice.
It's unique.
Nobody else does it in Malawi.
Maybe it's, the closest you can
come is what you call yodeling.
You know, I think here
that's what you do.
Just listen to what it does.
[ Music ]
That's a typical, thank you, that's
a typical Giddes Chalamanda song.
You know? He does what he was
telling you about that he is unique.
You know, I can't do what he does.
I don't know how he got it.
I think that's [inaudible] believe
that music is a natural
in born talent.
Either you are Giddes
Chalamanda or not.
You know? We have only
one Giddes Chalamanda.
His wife is called Abiti Alafuledi.
And there is a special song that he
did, but, you know, it seems to me
that he did this song
before she became the wife.
I don't know.
Maybe. I don't know [laughter].
And what he talks about in this
song is not very wife-husband stuff
because he is saying that she left
him and ran off to another man to,
you know, Zambia, the
border, the bordering country
that the Ambassador
was talking about.
So, maybe there's a second song that
she came back [multiple speakers].
Yeah. You know, she
[multiple speakers] passport.
And he's wondering, you know, having
gone through the visa applications
and all that I think she can't
understand how did she pull it off.
She ran out with another man,
you know, very [inaudible].
OK.
[ Music ]
[ Applause ]
I don't know how one can manage to
sing so happy about a woman who,
you know, it's one of
his most danceable tunes.
But I don't know if I am allowed
to say that we have these CDs here.
Am I allowed to say that?
OK. I don't know what you're
going to do then [laughter].
All right.
Mr. Giddes Chalamanda has been,
you know, out of Malawi before.
He worked, I think he went to work
in the 1930s, '40s as a teenager
because he was born in 1931.
So, you know, he would
have been a teenager
around late '40s and early '50s.
He worked in Zimbabwe and I
think after I came to know him,
we were lucky to have some people
who invited him to Germany twice.
He has been to Germany twice.
But on this particular trip, we
had to do some fundraising shows
because we didn't have any,
you know, funders for the trip,
but we really wanted to make
sure that his dream is realized.
So, he's here basically because
the people of Malawi, you know,
well wishers can, you know,
everybody gave him something
to make the trip possible.
And we are being hosted by Mr.
[inaudible] wonderful gentleman
who is wearing, you
know, he is very modest.
[ Applause ]
>> Edgar Kachere: Also not
forgetting our Ambassador.
>> Davis Njobvu: Yes.
>> Edgar Kachere: Who was very
instrumental in making sure
that we got the visas to come here.
>> Davis Njobvu: That's right.
Yes. Yes.
>> Edgar Kachere: It was a
bit difficulty and tricky
to get all these people, you know,
come together with the visas.
>> Davis Njobvu: Yes.
>> Edgar Kachere: So, the Ambassador
is very handy in doing that.
A big hand for him.
[ Applause ]
>> Davis Njobvu: We
are honored to be here.
And, indeed, the Ambassador
has kept to his word.
We knew that, you know, in the
Ambassador's hands we are very safe.
He said, "You know, if you come to
America, we will take care of you,
and he is taking care of us.
This coming to the Library
of Congress, you know,
is actually his initiative.
So, for that we are honored.
There's a song that Mr. Giddes
Chalamanda did way back.
It's a folk tale.
It talks about a snake.
I've seen a DVD of him
playing this song in Germany.
So, I would like him to do what
he did to introduce the song.
Mr. Giddes, Napolo.
What is Napolo?
>> Giddes Chalamanda:
Napolo is a big snake.
>> Davis Njobvu: What of it?
>> Giddes Chalamanda: Big
snake, Napolo [inaudible].
>> Davis Njobvu: An Englishman?
An Englishman?
>> Giddes Chalamanda: [Multiple
Speakers] He was living
in his own body.
He was [inaudible].
>> Davis Njobvu: OK.
>> Giddes Chalamanda: Now,
he [inaudible] wrong way.
I don't know [inaudible].
That time when he was
coming from a long way,
he came [inaudible] deliver,
deliver [inaudible] to make it in.
When [inaudible] up,
when he [inaudible] he
had a [inaudible] order.
Now he said too much
loading up on the water.
He said [inaudible]
said [inaudible].
>> Davis Njobvu: People
were warning him.
>> Giddes Chalamanda: Yeah.
>> Davis Njobvu: OK.
>> Giddes Chalamanda: That
time [inaudible] drowning
because of that snake.
>> Davis Njobvu: They capsized.
OK. All right.
>> Giddes Chalamanda:
Now he is now dead.
His wife is crying.
>> Davis Njobvu: How did she cry?
>> Giddes Chalamanda: She cried
and said, "My husband has died.
Has gone away."
>> Davis Njobvu: Yes.
>> Giddes Chalamanda: And
[inaudible] Napolo [inaudible].
>> Davis Njobvu: A very sad story.
What this song talks about, I don't
know, here you call it flash floods.
And back in Malawi, you
know, it's not flash floods.
There's a snake that
lives in the mountain.
This snake decides, you know,
when it pleases to move,
you know, maybe go around.
So, it comes from one mountain,
maybe moving to another part, maybe,
you know, to go to
Zambia across the border.
So, it sweeps whatever
it finds in its way.
And Mr. Ingram typically of an
English person didn't listen
to the warnings that
the villagers told him.
You know, they said
there is a snake here.
And [inaudible] said
I'll drive past.
Unfortunately, he became
history and he became a song.
So, in the song, the
wife is crying, you know?
"My husband has gone away."
So, that is the song that Mr.
Giddes Chalamanda is talking about,
this snake that took
away [inaudible] is
like [inaudible] the boss.
OK.
[ Music ]
[ Applause ]
Thank you.
In the song he also
mentions his mother.
You know? Mr. Giddes Chalamanda's
songs are quite lauded because,
you know, in there he talks
about his children, his wife,
the village, you know, Malawi.
I think he has given
a brief introduction
about the country of Malawi.
He said something like we
use, we use needles to eat.
You know? And he actually
also interprets
to say by that he means forks.
Yeah? Here, come to Malawi.
We eat with fingers and needles.
You know, we can choose whatever.
That's what he says.
One of the things I
wanted you to know is
that Mr. Giddes Chalamanda
plays the guitar.
These songs that we're
playing, he composed,
he composed the music
and, you know, everything.
In fact, he's very particular
about how we should play
the guitar [laughter].
Last night he was trying
to teach me a new song.
You know? So, he wasn't very happy
with the way we were playing it.
He wants the guitar to
sound the way he plays it.
And I can get quite [inaudible]
if it's not coming out
the way you want it.
So, if you see him
frowning just know
that I'm not [inaudible] the music.
It's not easy, you know,
to play the way he plays.
Let's see if we can give you,
there's a song that he did
for women, you know,
the women of Malawi.
>> Edgar Kachere: Yes.
>> Davis Njobvu: But, you know,
we believe a woman is created
as a woman, so this song, although
it is talking about the women
of Malawi, it applies to
the women of America as well
and all the ladies in the house.
OK. I will not say what it says.
I will let him [laughter].
All right.
[ Music ]
[ Applause ]
Mr. Giddes Chalamanda is quite a
very well liked figure amongst,
you know, people.
It's the same wherever we've gone.
Especially young ladies
that like him so much.
I don't know.
Maybe they think of
their grandfathers.
But we usually get in trouble
with young ladies wanting to come
and get photographed with him.
And they like to post on Facebook.
Right now in Malawi they're actually
sending us questions to say, OK,
so what exactly is
happening here [laughter]?
You know because they, they
just like to do that, you know?
It's something that we
can't explain especially
because my colleague here thought
maybe he would be the one getting
all that [laughter].
>> Edgar Kachere: Yeah.
I thought I would get
the attention but.
>> Davis Njobvu: It's not
quite happening that way.
>> Edgar Kachere: We
are not there yet.
We are not there yet.
But we will get there, you know?
>> Davis Njobvu: One day.
It gives us a little
of encouragement.
>> Edgar Kachere: Yes.
>> Davis Njobvu: You know, we are
looking forward to getting old and,
you know, being like Mr. Chalamanda.
We are going to play
our own songs as well.
>> Edgar Kachere: Just maybe
two songs because of the time.
>> Davis Njobvu: Yeah.
Yes.
>> Edgar Kachere: So you
see what we have as well.
>> Davis Njobvu: Exactly.
>> Edgar Kachere: Taught
by Mr. Giddes Chalamanda.
>> Davis Njobvu: Yes.
We've been influenced
by Mr. Giddes Chalamanda
and quite [inaudible] musicians
that we've come across.
We are [inaudible] as a band.
We play also live,
you know, heavy band.
But this is how we started out.
Very acoustic.
But we like it, you know?
We can adapt to any situations.
Our music contains a lot
of education and messages
but we fuse it with a lot of humor.
And as the Ambassador
said, double meanings.
We don't mean to say
anything really.
It's up to the people to
interpret the way they see it.
This one talks about [inaudible].
>> Edgar Kachere: Yes.
>> Davis Njobvu: Yeah
[inaudible] can mean the job.
The job.
>> Edgar Kachere: It
means a profession.
>> Davis Njobvu: It can.
>> Edgar Kachere: Some
jobs are dangerous.
Some professions are dangerous
like the law profession
[multiple speakers].
Yeah. So, we say that some
occupations can be very hazardous
especially, you know,
if they require to come
in contact with certain situations.
Yes. People of the opposite making.
>> Davis Njobvu: Yeah.
As well as people of similar making.
>> Edgar Kachere: Of course.
Of course [multiple speakers].
It's a very dangerous
job being a tailor.
>> Davis Njobvu: Yeah.
Yes. Because you have to take
measurements of a woman [laughter].
>> Edgar Kachere: Yes.
Yes.
>> Davis Njobvu: Even a pastor too.
>> Edgar Kachere: Even a pastor
sometimes when you're a priest.
>> Davis Njobvu: Yes.
>> Edgar Kachere: Because
it's very difficult as well
because they have to
work at all hours.
>> Davis Njobvu: And you
ask to close your eyes.
>> Edgar Kachere: Yes.
>> Davis Njobvu: Yeah.
So, that's.
>> Edgar Kachere: Yes.
In front of a woman.
>> Davis Njobvu: Or anywhere else.
All right.
OK.
>> Edgar Kachere: Even as a lawyer.
>> Davis Njobvu: Yeah.
Yeah. Yes.
So, that's what this
song talks about.
As you can see it talks about
occupations, professions.
Nothing else.
OK?
[ Music ]
[ Applause ]
>> Edgar Kachere: You know,
because of time, because of time,
we'll give you one last one.
This one, you know,
I turn 38 the day
after tomorrow [inaudible] my
colleague in two months time.
So, he always that go
where he wants to go.
>> Davis Njobvu: Follow me.
>> Edgar Kachere: So,
he says I follow him.
>> Davis Njobvu: He
always follows me.
>> Edgar Kachere: So, he is
telling me please don't follow me,
but I always follow him.
I know it.
[Inaudible] was the
name of this song.
[Inaudible] is the name
back home in Malawi.
So, he says I'm the naughty one.
but who is the naughty one here
because I'm following his footsteps.
>> Davis Njobvu: No.
No. No. No.
No. No.
>> Edgar Kachere: You take what I do
and then you turn it
back [inaudible].
>> Davis Njobvu: Yeah.
Yeah.
>> Edgar Kachere: Because I do it.
Not you.
>> Davis Njobvu: Yeah.
Yeah. You see, he is following.
He is a copycat.
I went to Ambassador Mhura,
you know, to teach me law.
He goes there after me.
You know?
>> Edgar Kachere: Mr. Mhura,
Ambassador Mhura [inaudible] said no
please don't follow your brother's
footsteps [inaudible].
Be a better student
please [laughter].
>> Davis Njobvu: But
it didn't work out.
So like [inaudible].
[ Music ]
[ Applause ]
Thank you.
That was a special
dedication to Mr. Edgar here.
>> Edgar Kachere: Thank
you very much.
>> Davis Njobvu: By me.
Yeah? Is it?
That's it.
OK. Thank you.
>> Edgar Kachere: We
thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Ambassador Necton Mhura:
Wasn't that wonderful?
>> Audience: Yes.
>> Ambassador Necton Mhura: Can we
give them another round of applause?
[ Applause ]
For someone at the age of 86 to be
able to perform and sing as well
as he does, it's a
great achievement.
You should have seen
him on Saturday.
The kind of energy that
Giddes Chalamanda has.
I mean, it puts some of us
younger people to shame.
It remains for me to appreciate
the fact that the younger people
who are supposed to be taking over
from Giddes Chalamanda have managed
to make his dream of coming
to America true and performing
at the Library of Congress is
part of that dream coming true.
And thank you so much
Edgar and Davis.
[ Applause ]
I may have taught these
young men law in law school
but I didn't teach them
their kind heartedness.
It came from their heart
and we appreciate that.
I didn't teach them music either.
I only taught them law.
I would also wish to thank you all
for coming to attend this concert.
Thank you for coming to
appreciate Malawian music.
I believe that that's only a
taste of what Malawi can offer.
And I would invite you to
sample what is available.
I believe the CDs will be available
for sale at some point as we go out.
But I also wish to thank
particularly Mary Jane Deeb,
the Director of the Department
that is hosting us this afternoon.
It was a chance meeting at which
we talked about the possibility
of these young men and
Giddes Chalamanda performing
at the Library of Congress.
And they agreed that they
should host the old man
in fulfillment of his dream.
And I thank you so
much for hosting us.
[ Applause ]
I must say that this event
would not have taken place
without Laverne Page.
I would like Laverne
Page to stand up please.
Well.
[ Applause ]
It was a, Madam Deeb put me
in the hands of Laverne to go
around the Library of Congress.
It was out of the conversation
with her that the idea
of performing here came up.
And she worked tirelessly.
Actually pushing me
and my staff and others
to make sure that this does happen.
Making all the behind
the scenes arrangements.
I would like to thank you
particularly Laverne for ensuring
that this indeed does happen
and it has taken place.
There are others behind the scene
who will have worked to make sure
that this event actually
takes place.
I would like to record my
thanks to them as well.
Once again, thank you all for
coming to attend this event
and I hope you have enjoyed the day.
[ Applause ]
Yes. One more from, yes?
If I had a choice I
would choose my own,
but I'm sure they have one ready.
[ Music ]
>> Davis Njobvu: We'll let him
choose a song [multiple speakers].
[ Music ]
He says [inaudible].
In this song, he is talking
about the death of his parents.
I think it must have been a very
sad time, you know, for him.
I know, you know, I've
gone through that.
He says, but the way he is,
you know, very artistic,
he says he was dreaming about
the death of his parents.
So, he is not talking about the time
that they actually died but the time
that he was dreaming about it.
I don't know whether
it was before or after
because he also says
now he is alone.
You know? Now he is alone.
He was dreaming about their death
but now he is alone
[multiple speakers].
OK. So [inaudible]
but that's the song.
[ Music ]
[ Applause ]
We hope this song is not prophetic
because it says he will die
far away from home [laughter].
>> Edgar Kachere: So,
please [inaudible].
We need to go back with him.
>> Davis Njobvu: I think
we need to [inaudible]
or Canada or somewhere, you know?
>> Edgar Kachere: At least not here.
>> Davis Njobvu: All right.
[ Applause ]
>> Announcer: This has
a been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.